we're going to drop right into the news
this hour and a conversation on an issue
that's affecting millions of american
families it's a health crisis that has
actually been overshadowed a bit by the
coronavirus but it's touching so many of
us it's the epidemic of drug overdoses
in the past year there have been more
than 107 000 overdose fatalities in this
country and the synthetic opioid
fentanyl is responsible for nearly 70 of
those deadly overdoses it's the leading
cause of death for people 18 to 45 years
old this sunday august 21st is national
fentanyl prevention and awareness day
and the u.s drug enforcement
administration the dea
is spearheading efforts to get the
substance off the streets and we are
joined now by dea administrator ann
milgram uh in an exclusive interview
something you'll see only on cbs
mornings thank you for being here
um i have the uh unusual disclosure off
the top of saying that the dea arrested
my father in the 90s but i hold no ill
will he was very guilty uh quite proud
of it actually uh but i want to get to
this uh topic uh at hand cause it's a
serious one uh the overdose numbers have
been getting worse for years now you've
been in the job for a little bit more
than a year what's your theory of the
case why are the numbers going in the
wrong direction well first of all thank
you for having me it's sunday's fentanyl
prevention day as you noted and it is so
important i think to have public
awareness and to be talking about
what is happening in our country
so what we see happening at dea is
essentially that there are two cartels
in mexico the sinaloa cartel and the
jalisco new generation cartel that are
killing americans with fentanyl at
catastrophic and record rates like we
have never seen before and those cartels
are acting with calculated deliberate
treachery to get fentanyl to the united
states and to get people to buy it
through fake pills by hiding it and
other drugs any means that they can take
in order to drive addiction and to make
money let's talk about the treachery and
the addiction because you know once upon
a time the theory of a drug dealer was
they wanted to keep a person addicted
keep them paying money but not kill them
and now we're seeing people die at an
incredibly high rate so what's changed
that that's totally right the whole
world of drugs have changed i mean first
of all the fentanyl that we see is
synthetic it's man-made so it's
important to know that there is an
unlimited amount that these two cartels
can make all they need are precursor
chemicals that they're buying from china
from these chinese chemical companies
bringing them to mexico and synthesizing
massive quantities so that's critically
important to understand the second piece
is that it used to be that drug deals
were hand to hand that they were in back
alleys or that they were connected to a
specific dealer that would meet someone
and you saw them face to face and you
saw them face to face that's totally
gone we live in a world now where
technology a digital age where social
media has become a super highway so for
a dealer for the criminal cartel sinaloa
and jalisco new generation cartel they
they want to relentlessly expand and the
way they do that is by driving addiction
and by selling more and more and so what
they'll do fentanyl is the most deadly
widespread drug we've ever seen if it
does not kill someone they the
likelihood of them becoming addicted and
buying more and more is very high so how
do they use the social media and that's
what i'm fascinated with because it's
targeting americans especially targeting
teenagers in several cases dr berman
joined us to talk about the tragic death
of her son and he's online on snapchat
she says and she has no idea what's
happening
she has no idea he was engaging in that
so how is it working so this we this
tragic story we hear i hear every single
day not isolated it's not isolated and
and what's happening is that social
media is it's essentially a super
highway it's also anonymous and again
think about you know someone doesn't
have to walk to a street corner to buy
drugs you have kids sitting in their
bedroom anyone with a smartphone has a
drug dealer with them so what does the
drug dealer do so what the drug dealer
does is they go on these on on any of
these platforms snapchat in particular
um we talk about a lot because it's used
frequently and they do it a lot of
different ways they may go into the
comments to people who are going to a
concert and start to target them and say
hey i'll be there do you want to meet up
they may post an emoji list but did they
say i'm going to sell you fentanyl
never so this is one of the things i
think it's most important for people to
understand when they go in they sell
they say i'm going to sell you an oxy
content pill i'm going to sell you an
adderall i'm going to sell you a
percocet as if it were real and this is
the deliberate calculated treachery of
the cartels they're lying to you so kids
think they're buying boxes
so
would you point out that snapchat says
that they've stepped up their
protections that they're trying to
educate their users and they're trying
to work with law enforcement so they've
got a pretty lengthy statement here
shutting down dealers improving our
support for law enforcement and
educating snapchatters about the fatal
dangers of counterfeit pills but
statement aside are you getting the help
and support you need from these
companies but i also think it's
important though the kids think they're
buying one thing yes do the pills look
similar they have no way of knowing that
they're getting fentanyl they shouldn't
be buying any of it i mean it shouldn't
be available through the phone right
about that but the fact is they are
buying it and but they don't think
they're buying fentanyl right exactly
they think they're buying oxy and i will
tell you if you put them side by side
you can't tell them you can't tell the
difference the lifelong professionals at
the dea can't tell the difference they
look exactly as if they're the real pill
and they have none of those ingredients
in it they're fentanyl
after
these companies that are facilitating
the sale of these narcotics to our
children so right now we are we are
actively investigating every single
possible lead we can take and we are
looking very much at what we can do in
the space our top priority is to defeat
the two cartels because to be really
clear there is an unlimited amount of
drugs that they can make we have to stop
it what before it comes from china to
mexico to the u.s the second piece is
that yes we have to be aggressive on
this
company's allies so i hear you on
snapchat's statement 107 622 americans
died last year we will see more deaths
this year and right now the prime way
there's no more dangerous place in the
united states of america for a young
person 18 to 45 right now than social
media and help me understand why would
they want to sell kids fentanyl knowing
that it could kill them and is killing
them why would they do that because what
the cartels want is they want money and
relentless expansion so they want to get
you addicted they want to get you
addicted and if you if you get addicted
you will buy more and more fentanyl
because fentanyl it is 50 times stronger
than heroin 100 times stronger than
morphine and it drives addiction and
people will buy more and more they don't
mind their death as a side effect and
one other point sorry
if they don't die if if they don't die
they become addicted and if someone dies
for the cartel there are 108 million
people on snapchat so the next person is
right behind the corner yeah exactly
another topic in the news i am really
curious threats against law enforcement
as the head of dea are you concerned
that the rhetoric out there politically
could lead to strikes against your
agents i am concerned i will tell you
that the men and women of the dea are
extraordinary we've been out we're out
every single day around the world on
countless operations our agents are in
harm's way we take loaded guns off the
street virtually every single day
across america and across the world so
threats against law enforcement concern
me and you know my top priority as the
administrator is the health and safety
of our workforce and concerned about you
too ann thank you very much for coming
in today and very glad to see you here
with very heavy security very glad to
see you here at the table